keystone ein alter [ __ ] ich hab noch
einen lebens knox hat noch drei scheiß
halt ok ok jungs schaffe ich das
schreibt seine kommentare schreibt seine
kommentare ob ihr denkt dass gäste
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde supersmart blablabla super smash
mops genau ich nehme hier die spinne und
zwar erkannt sich hieraus geht direkt
los wir können uns hier verschiedene
mops aussuchen das alles ultra mops für
die leute die ultra gekauft haben lassen
für die normalen leute die sich normale
normale leute und ich bin ich spinne die
ganzen sachen die ich kann er zeige ich
euch gleich noch und zwar so warte ich
zeigt sich gleich ich kann erst mal mit
der mit der axt hier kann ich einen
spinnweben schleudern auf einen gegner
der dann darin gefangen ist die mit
schlage ich halt so ganze mal was ich
hiermit recht machen kann es halt auch
noch pfeile schießen also hier zb die
pfeile schießen so alle zwei jahre zum
beispiel hier so spinnennetz spätestens
jetzt wo ist denn die bei solchen leuten
kann man das gut machen
die jetzt so langsam sind im golem oder
so da ist zum beispiel an man muss
natürlich auch treffen mit doppel space
kann ich dann so doppelt spring und ist
der stil des spiels ist halt dass man
als längst aber lebt mehr oder weniger
als einer minute special attack landet
so der ezb darin gefangen jetzt den
boxen seite habe ich gelesen balanciert
festplatte gehe ich nicht
man kann also doppelt springen mit
doppel space hiermit kann man auch noch
pfeile schießen das macht halt immer die
spinnen geräusch gehört sind springen
wir euch schon diese erfahrung ist wenn
die leer ist dann kann ich das nicht
mehr machen
das ist besonders hier auf ich will
sogar auf diese spinnweben gezogen so
und ja wie gesagt hier ist es halt dass
man so lange wie möglich überlebt und
jeder moped bestimmte eigenschaften wenn
ich ultra haben sollte was ich mir
eventuell kaufen werde oder ich bekomm
youtube biaggi ich hab keine ahnung
werde ich euch mal jeden mod vorstellen
also auf jeden fall winter skeleton weil
darauf habe ich richtig bock offen
auf dem river skeleton weil damit kann
man so gut taktik machen weil man kann
mit ihm weder skeletten in südlohn also
ein duplikat von einem selbst bauen
so kommen hoch pokern hoch scheiße
man kann damit ein duplikat von einem
vorne damit kann man echt sogar ihre
taktik machen scheiße ich muss mal gab
ein bisschen weg laufen hier ein
bisschen angst transporter hinter fläche
schon wieder ein alter [ __ ] my man ein
alter [ __ ] ich bin aber gestorben jetzt
mich einfach sind zu dritt okay gut ich
habe aber noch drei leben im gegensatz
zu den anderen ob noch drei leben
das heißt man muss quasi abwarten aber
es geht auch so ein bisschen nach
punkten wie viele leute mag hielt
deswegen ich werde jetzt mal so ein
bisschen nach taktik gehen so du
komplett verschwindet dann fackelt habe
ich ihr nie drin mitbringt einfach mal
nichts vom ruhig hochkultur scheiße
alter scheiße mann ich muss ein bisschen
hier mehr auf verteidigung gehen
ich gehe zwar angriff des todes aber ich
muss mir jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert
du sollst man hier mit spinnweben und
links ran wo alter der hammer geil
ein junge steht doch bekämpft euch doch
gegenseitig alter warum gehen ihr
dennoch nicht
jahrhundert er geht dahin geht uns
gegenseitig auf euch mal glaubte machen
team die beiden schicken box und kriegt
ja okay wenn ihr auch chicken box und
clipper box heißen werden die
wahrscheinlich zu machen und auf mich
gehen damit die in diesem finale machen
oder so zusammen aber nicht mit mir
alten punkt auseinander
und jetzt steckt die selber mein ding
von ihr
julius webshopping man sieht auch nie
was von den anderen im chat jetzt
natürlich durch dass ich hier so einem
team erwischt habe die tun jetzt
wahrscheinlich sonst würden sich
irgendwie bekämpfen oder so und treffen
sich dann gegenseitig extra nicht damit
die dann nicht helfen können okay einer
steelbox hat nur noch ein leben ich habe
noch zwei weniger box tod hat ist
erstmal gut dann kann ich auf chicken
box gehen
okay ist tot
ein alter [ __ ] ich habe noch einen leben
jobs hat noch drei scheiße alte ok ok
jungs schaffe ich das schreibt seine
kommentare schreibt seine kommentare ob
ihr denkt dass es noch schaffe ich weiß
es nicht ich bin ja ein kack in sowas
alter also er hat jetzt natürlich werde
jetzt natürlich echt ein vorteil dass er
hier ihr wisst bescheid leute was no ok
dann bleibt der gewinnt ich mache jetzt
mal so gut
also er hat mich nicht ich komme zu ihm
halter des gut ich sehe da schon
weidmann
okay okay okay jetzt noch ein leben hat
jetzt noch ein leben hatte noch ein
leben ja heute noch ein leben gut ich
musste erst mal wieder ein bisschen
aufladen ich hoffe mal der komplett in
die zu mir
wo ist er denn größer der us agenda ok
ok ich muss mein leben aufladen los
leben laden schneller kommt er kommt er
kommt leben geht hier um leben und tod
ok bis zu der kontrakte das tut nicht
erkannt ja bist in der aufschlag und
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein jetzt
träger sich richtig an alter stätte
schnell luca los [ __ ] alter ich muss auf
jeden fall mein leben jetzt mal aufladen
ganze noch in der lobby dann bleiben
weil es nicht muss weg eigentlich
musikkorps das tor fällt jetzt einblicke
sich das hier zusammen schreibe ich
dachte so ein spannender wettkampf macht
mit dem macht spaß h
ja ohne witz ich mag es auch englisch
bist du wohl hinter dir jetzt kommt
scheiße was bringt denn das schaffen
einfach fakten ein alter scheiße
[ __ ] alter nein erklärte ich die spinne
ist jetzt auch nicht so gute klasse
womit man nicht so taktisch vorgehen
kann
scheiße alter los jungs hängen rundeten
dran hier noch was hinten dranhängen
waren noch einen rang dahinter dann so
das ist halt das coole man ist sofort
wieder drin in der lobby und dann geht
sofort wieder los also ich nehm jetzt
mal eine andere klassen die spinne kennt
ihr ja jetzt
ich nehme jetzt einfach das recht nehmen
also das kann man sich mit jeans
freischalten 6000 ich habe 5000 männer
nehmen
okay okay okay jungs dann mache ich
jetzt eine spinnerin dem spiel eine
spinne ich bin ja ganz gut klargekommen
der spinne waren ein paar blöde ding ist
aber okay die kripo box und die haben
wieder diese anderen komische leute hält
pilz also ich hoffe mal es wird jetzt
besser
ich hoffe dass ich jetzt mal gewinnen
gar nicht ob man gut passt macht mir die
karte ist aber geil aussieht
er geht er geht direkt hier auf mich als
hunde
gründe sind das alter stimmt
ok ich fände es mich
ich heiße man nicht ab zweieinhalb
herzen nein okay für tot
ich will jetzt erst mal ein bisschen
bisschen abwarten was die beiden machen
schicken box hat aber auch noch drei
leben aber das ist auch keine diese
spinne die ist echt die hat keine
richtige power oder so ich kann halt nur
hier
ich kann er ab jetzt halt hier noch
pfeile schießen aber die fallen halt
auch noch zeit dann wieder runter bis
dann auch in die luft weder schon und
man kann hat nichts mehr mit den ganzen
sachen und hat halt immer so ein kleines
delay
wo alte kein bisschen angst dass ich
hier rum chs rum
okay das drin im spiel jedoch nicht aber
das schicken alter das war nur ein
kleiner schritt den ich gerade getötet
habe
dass sie mal hier hoch alter lasse mich
mal hier hoch bu alter leute ok leben
aufladen leben aufladen runterkommen
luca alles wird gut
okay die boxen sich da hinten gerade ich
schick damals einfach ein paar pfeile
hierhin nein da kommen die da von der
seite nein das schaffe ich auch keinen
kleinsten auf kleinsten alter auf
kleinsten nein ein junge mit einem
herzen ein alter okay zwei leben noch
mal ein bisschen motto man kann ich hoch
wie diese neue hof gekommen
der wahrscheinlich
steht doch alter ich boxe auf ihn eine
stewardess ja ok jukic fehlten
okay ein leben noch einleben chicken box
hat auch noch einen leben die anderen
noch zwei und ich werde direkt wieder
hey warum ist ja nicht mein leben teil
drin runterfiel grund heftig runter
ja okay er ist tot es tot jetzt wieder
leben auf landleben aufladen jungs
lebenden aufladen
okay okay okay ihr könnt mir über uns
aber leute eine kommentare schritt den
ich dass eventuell mehr spielen soll
irgendwie max simon p den ihr wollt
watch schluss als es macht mir auf jeden
fall haben sie gerne und ob ihr aber
hammergeil viel spaß solche wo diese
ganzen modi auf meint exel ich liebe
diesen körper ja ja ja ja ja ja ohne
witz nur noch keeper boxen ich alter
genauso wie vorhin ok hammergeil jetzt
noch ihrem leben aufladen so ein
bisschen zeit ändern schreibt bitte
schreib ja oder so ok
er ist gefangen jetzt gefangen jetzt
gefangen jetzt gefangen ich hab das netz
kaputtmacht scheiße ja was los ja man
gewonnen
jung ich hatte ganz kurz vorher noch
einen noch einleben alter und dann habe
ich das taktisch noch relativ gut
gemacht und damit spinnweben und support
dieses spiel vor dass es zu geil ich
liebe dieses spiel dann gibt's noch eine
runde dran packen
aber leute doch eine runde dann schaffen
wir erschaffen 4000 leichtes community
alter menschen hammer geil einfach ich
noch eine runde dann also laut morgen
noch eine runde hoch und dann will ich
sagen sehen uns dann eventuell morgen
wieder wenn ihr schafft und dann tot bis
morgen